do you like producing or acting better i
like both
honestly but i definitely want to do
more producing as well like
it just feels you know in life like as
you a little bit of ownership
yeah exactly well and even collaborating
though that's what's so we were telling
me
we ran into each other years ago yes and
i literally left going oh my god i just
met jesse spano
it's freaking out and but anytime i'm
freaking out probably over here you're
freaking out over there because like i'm
obsessed with your music well
we had a freakout moment together then
but yeah now we're here
and you're doing say by the bell the
reunion so i think this is so the reboot
is so cool
i had uh mario on and we were talked
about it because i already
got really mad at him why because he was
the first casper to come and i was like
hey um i knew the whole theme song like
i'm a really great jingle singer i could
have done
a theme song you could have done it oh
my god i would have
you have no idea i'm freaking out every
episode at 10 a.m every morning in texas
it's fine
so like is that kind of cool getting
back like so many years later it is
honestly it's the best like the core
four of us have never stopped being in
touch
we are we are friends i know their
children
i'm friends with their spouses we you
know so to then drop back in
i remember sitting across from mario
like the first day of shooting at the
max
and i'm looking yeah and i'm sitting
there looking at this face that i have
known 30 years we were
truly children when we started i know if
someone had told me then
that i would see him you know this many
years later back as that character i
wouldn't have believed it
i know but it was such a huge pop
culture
moment like few people are part of
something that massive that that makes
such an
impact so my question i asked him so ac
slater is now the athletic director
yes so who is jesse spanish so jesse
in perfect jessie spano form is the
guidance counselor
okay cause like you know even back in
the day with the og
friends she was always the advice giver
yeah she was always
um wanting to help people and she was an
advocate for so many different causes
yeah and her son jamie is a student here
so she's a bit of a helicopter parent
and that's comedy ensues
[Music]